so really nice not to the Philly Flyers
with the sweatshirts very subtle I like
that was it was one of the things that I
wanted to really incorporate was the
kind of like the Philadelphia hometown
you know kind of gear in in in the show
so we were fortunate to do that the
first season we did a lot of flyers
because I'm affiliated with the
organization and a great team obviously
it's my favorite team and I do some work
with them and so we incorporate a little
bit of that in the action and got some
Eagles in there so I kind of think it
fits Jason Hayes personality so season
one ends in a cliffhanger where do we
pick up and season two well there's been
a fracture in the team so it's really
about the whole bringing it back Thank
You Brent getting that unity back and we
pick up about six months later after the
so called injury that Jason is dealing
with and everyone's kind of moved in
different directions back home and we
deal with with that aspect of it what
happens in their home lives when they
come back from a deployment and so the
first five episodes are pretty heavy I'm
excited to see these characters kind of
deal with their own personal problems
and their their problems at home and
eventually how they come back together
is quite remarkable and it's a heavy
heavy five episodes I was gonna say
because Sony's sort of left hanging
we're wondering what happens with him
dealing with depression so you know
where does his where's Jason's
relationship pickup with Mandy mm-hmm
there's a lot I mean you it's there's so
much to look into with these characters
when they're out working and doing their
job and they're deployed and they are
under a one-unit team you know and they
come back home it's a whole different
story and being able to get them under
that and microscope that is I think it's
very important what's more difficult for
Jason navigating life off you know off
the military base or in civilian life
well you know it's two different worlds
I mean when they enter mix which will
see the season after episode five it
becomes a little bit of an issue for him
how he can handle that stress and that
pressure without giving away too many
spoilers because I don't want to do that
but you know it's tough for guys when
they come back home and with this show
we're able to do that and that
this year we're really gonna dive into
that and I think it's really important
you've got two Canadians on your caste
AJ and Jessica Perry that's about
working with both of them great well I'm
kind of Canadian I was born in Buffalo
so it's just a peace bridge away
Falls Ontario I know the area very well
so I would kind of consider myself a
somewhat quote/unquote canady yes I
could see honorary Canadian I could say
Canuck right okay not the full Canadian
but a Canuck sure is that is that
acceptable
okay now we it's great I mean Jessica's
great
AJ's hilarious plays a great character
and we'll see a lot between them this
year especially with Mandy and Jason's
kind of give and take back and forth
what her her job is and getting things
done and how Jason kind of gets into
that after seat episode five and how
he's got to deal with some personal
issues that are pretty heavy and how it
affects him being a Tier one leader and
you know AJ is he's his character
dealing with all his his depression and
PTSD and you know the good news is the
teams do get back together I will say
that but it'll be different how its
operated that's for sure introducing new
characters in season two yes we have
some new characters
it's what's exciting about network
television so it's actor entities new
characters I think down the line well
we'll see the the first five episodes
kind of go into this personal home front
then we'll go off to Mexico City and
deal with a problem and an issue we're
actually in that kind of Sicario world
we'll come back and then it will be
deployed into the Philippines in the
back half and probably in that back half
we'll see some character where we'll
maybe affect Jason's life and we'll see
how that works out but other than that
we have a new yo D bomb specialist who
was a fantastic guy he's joined the team
and you know we're so excited to see
whoever else comes on board and
see what happens acting starring I
should say producing directing how do
you keep it all straight yeah I just
just blessed one step at a time it's a
lot of fun I enjoy it I think that it's
a great character to play I love the
environment that we're in with all these
creative people and I think John Glenn's
doing such a fantastic job you know
running this second season and you know
we just hit the stride of kind of the
camaraderie between all of us and the
cast and the crew and it makes it easy
you know when you're in when you're here
works long hours so yeah I like it enjoy
it you guys are dealing with some pretty
heavy subject matter how are you keeping
things light off set you know what we're
we're clowns so there's always tear when
operators or a bunch of clowns think
pretty funny and they got it they
literally are they take things to the
extreme and as our characters do and
that leads to some pretty funny moments
off off set like partying moments no no
no we're very responsible are you
pulling pranks on each other what do you
mean well sure we can pull pranks on
people you know that just depends on the
environment where we're at that's all
you're like no comment no comment okay
all right I want to explore or talk
about I love how the show sort of it
explores the intersection between
emotional fear and reason and how those
two sort of like you know at the
second-to-last episode where you know
Ray is telling Jason like you're just
being too emotional you're making this
decision out of emotion yeah you just
kind of expand tier-one operators I mean
Tier one operators they they just
generally they do their job they get it
done whatever the cost is they just keep
pushing through it they don't think with
feelings they are their automatic and
there's just so trained to do that when
things get kind of sticky at the
homefront and they start to bleed into
their professional lives for what they
do it can get a little I would say
confusing for them how they deal with
that the choices they make while they're
on a mission who to get how to control
that situation in that environment it
gets out of control
so all those elements kind of play into
place